[Music]
well good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight
gun control saves lives that's what
they're telling you
day and night on cnn in fact they're
having a town hall meeting tomorrow to
tell you some more
anyone who opposes gun control they'll
tell you by implication if not directly
is a bad person a callous cruel probably
violent person
someone who doesn't care about the
safety of others well last night a group
of progressive activists took that very
message
to senate majority leader mitch
mcconnell's home here's what they said
we're at mcconnell's house this i think
he's about to get some rest
not if the kill the children that you're
kidnapping can't get any rest not in
families who are getting murdered can't
get any rest
he's in there nursing his little broken
arm he should have broke his little
raggedy wrinkled ass neck
murder
[Applause]
stab him in the heart break his neck
that's the last message for mitch
mcconnell they're
totally opposed to violence and that's
why they want to kill mitch mcconnell
if you're confused you haven't been
paying much attention lately almost
everything the left says these days is
projection
in almost every single case they accuse
you
of exactly what they're doing and this
week was no different
in the wake of two horrifying mass
shootings they've been telling us the
president
is a hater he's using race to divide us
they scream
it's wrong well they're right about the
second part it's definitely wrong
but using race to divide us that's a
core tenant of the left
identity politics is the process of
dividing people
on the basis of immutable
characteristics factors they can't
control
and that's what the democratic party is
at this point it's an identity politics
party
they promise some americans reparations
they denounce others for their skin
color
they call it privilege the entire
country they'll tell you
is fundamentally racist and therefore
evil
this country was founded on white
supremacy and every single institution
and structure that we have in our
country still reflects the legacy
of slavery and segregation and jim crow
and suppression even in our democracy we
can't be blind to the impact of
generations
of racism and white supremacy that were
written
into our laws over centuries
so they're buffoons yes they are they're
dumb
of course do they have any idea what
they're really saying probably not
but that doesn't make the cumulative
effect any less sinister or damaging
what you're watching which you saw in
those tapes which you're watching every
day
is a systematic effort by the left to
undermine the institutions
that hold this country together chief
among those institutions
in this and all societies throughout
time is law enforcement our justice
system
over the past 25 years that's been a
success story
america's cops have radically reduced
crime across this nation
they brought our cities back to life if
you don't know that you're obviously
under 40.
ask anybody who lived in new york city
in 1991
what it was like if that person's honest
you'll be grateful for what the cops did
but now
on the basis of no evidence whatsoever
the left is telling us
police are racist monsters
i have challenged our police department
to recognize all of the ways in which
the uniform
has been burdened by racism we're going
to crack
down on police brutality aimed primarily
at people of color training for police
officers
on implicit racial bias and procedural
justice because to deny it exist
is to deny folks liberty and in many
cases life
how can we continue to lose the lives of
unarmed black men
in the united states of america at the
hands of white police officers
that is not justice if you are young and
black
you're treated differently because of
the color of your skin
i don't believe that it's just a case of
a few bad apples
i believe that the system is broken
imagine if you were a cop or your dad
was a cop or your son was
having to sit and watch that slander day
after day
again on the basis of no evidence
they're saying that it's disgusting
dividing us oh yes they're dividing us
how about our thousands of ice agents
working to enforce laws
that the congress passed the congress
passes the laws
and then hires people and doesn't pay
them all that much to enforce
their laws now democrats are calling
those people
nazis good people doing a thankless job
that we need to have
done only to have some pampered [ __ ]
like ocasio-cortez
savage them for political reasons none
of this is new by the way
three years ago you remember hillary
clinton ran an entire presidential
campaign on this premise
attacking the country itself and its
people as immoral bigots
you can put half of trump supporters
into what i call the basket of
deplorables
racist sexist homophobic xenophobic
islamophobic you name it
that's a message of unity no it's a
message of disunity it's a message of
hate
actually think through the implications
of it ray says sex says xenophobic
what do you do to people like that do
you try and help them do you feel like
they're your
countrymen your brothers now they're
horrible
you try to destroy them and they are
trying to destroy them
yesterday texas democratic congressman
joaquin castro
we're not making this up by the way
tweeted out the names of 44
residents of san antonio who've donated
to donald trump's presidential campaign
a legal activity but he tweeted them out
and then he tweeted out the names of
their employers too
why do you think he did that you know
the answer how'd you feel tonight if you
were one of those people would you feel
safe
no you wouldn't that's fine with
congressman castro though his point is
really clear you know exactly why he did
that if someone gets hurt that's not his
problem
you can see where this is going it
wasn't that long ago the boston globe
ran an op-ed suggesting that restaurant
workers poisoned the food of trump
supporters
and of course democrats have been
calling on people to harass and scream
at people
tied to the trump administration for
years they've been saying that go to the
hill today
get up and please get up in the face of
some congress people
if you see anybody from that cabinet in
a restaurant
in a department store at a gasoline
station
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so yes these people are buffoons
and it's our fault sometimes if we're
being honest including this show for
highlighting what buffoons they are
because by doing that we underplay how
dangerous
their rhetoric is our democratic system
only works when citizens are free to
disagree
free to say to their neighbors we're on
separate pages we vote for separate
people and not be afraid to say that
but the left is making us afraid to say
that the left demands total conformity
they don't believe in diversity in any
sense they'll use censorship and threats
to keep people in line
and in the short term that may work
they're hoping it works till next
november
but over time it's a big mistake it's
exactly how things fall apart